hi everyone I can't see you but I'm so
excited to see you this is actually my
first time back in the Bay Area in more
than a year I've been living in England
for the past year with my family and I
just could not miss this day so here I
am back for 24 hours jet lag and all so
hopefully I can deliver this okay in one
piece before I get started I just would
love to just take a moment to thank the
women who've recently come forward so
bravely on the record to speak out about
the sexual harassment they faced working
in Silicon Valley
I just cannot thank them enough they're
my heroes hopefully their actions will
cause more women to speak up and help
put an end to the discrimination and the
harassment that we as women can face
working in the startup community so one
more round of applause where am I here
all right here we go so last year if you
are here you'll remember that I spoke
about all the problems that can arise in
a startup and how to avoid them and to
be honest I think last year's talk with
the best general startup advice I could
give you so if you haven't read it
please
go to this link and read it and even if
you have read at its source or reread
because these are the type of problems
that can get you even when you think
you're already watching out for them so
there's the link last year I ended by
saying that I want there to be more
women founders of the big company
the so-called uniform and these are the
founders who make the most influential
role models and role models are what we
need most if you want to encourage more
women to start their own company in
recent years there's been an increase in
the number of women who are starting
startups and in the number of women
who've raised significant seed and
series a around and this is good
but now we've got to focus on the next
target we need to have more women of who
are founding billion-dollar startup so
that's what I'm going to talk about
today what it takes to start a startup
it's not merely successful but is
massively successful and I'm not saying
everyone has to do this you don't have
to start a startup and if you do you
don't have to start a Google but if you
do want to start a Google what does it
take what's the difference between a
successful startup and a massively
successful startup and fortunately I've
seen enough of both types at close hand
that I can see patterns of differences
we've made a list of things that I think
are different about the unicorn and
there are nine of them I want to get
this one out of the way from the very
start in addition to having everything
else that they need the unicorns are
lucky and one of the most important
kinds of luck is timing the most
successful founders have the right idea
at the right time and you have less
control over that then you might think
actually because the best ideas are not
deliberate they tend to grow organically
out in the founders lives however while
the most successful founders are all
lucky they're not merely lucky it's
never like they have this great idea and
then BOOM a few years later they're a
billionaire far far from that
one of the most noticeable difference
between founders of the super successful
startups and the moderately successful
startups is their motive and in
particular the founders of the super
successful startups never are in it
mainly to get rich or to seem cool
they're always fanatically interested in
what the company is doing incidentally
it's perfectly fine to start a start-up
mainly for the money but unless your
motives change throughout the course of
it it probably won't wind up being one
of the big ones there are multiple
reasons why startups do better when the
founders are truly interested in the
idea they work harder because they love
the work and their enthusiasm is
infectious they think longer-term and
they're much harder for another company
to capture with an acquisition offer
because they don't actually want to quit
so this one is going to sound really
obvious be it to be a huge start-up you
have to have a huge market you have to
make something that a lot of people will
pay for or that people will pay a lot
for and this one place lucky actually
has a very big effect because market
sizes are impossible to predict
for example the Airbnb didn't know how
many people would want to stay in other
people's homes all they knew was that
enough wood to make it an idea that was
worth working on the founders of most
successful startups never realized early
on how big they're going to get so our
advice at Y Combinator is not even to
try to hit a big market early on since
you can't predict these things it's
better just to work on something you
yourself want and then hope that there
are lots more people like you when you
describe the biggest startups most all
of them are doing something very basic
Google is how you find and for me
Facebook is where your friends are uber
gives you rides Airbnb gives you
somewhere to sleep these are all things
you could explain in a few words to a
five-year-old however don't use this as
a test for what to work on because ideas
often start out less general at first
Facebook wasn't where everyone's friends
were they were where a couple thousand
Harvard students were a sight for a
couple thousand students at one college
doesn't sound like a very promising idea
does it it may seem promising now
because we all know how the story turned
out but at the time it did not almost
all the really big startup ideas seemed
dubious at first I know exactly how
Airbnb z' idea seemed at first because I
was one of the people whose job it was
to judge it and I didn't think much of
it at the time to be perfectly honest
and it's not just that these ideas don't
seem as big at first as they eventually
turn out to be they seem to most people
like bad ideas you need to be a certain
type of person who can work on one of
these bad ideas that eventually turns
into a good one you need to be
independent minded you cannot care what
other people think it's now kind of part
of the conventional picture of a
successful founder to be a maverick and
that part of the conventional picture is
accurate I really I can't think of one
that I would describe as a conformist
you also have to be ambitious because
what happens with these initially on
promising ideas is that they blossom
into terrifyingly big ones you start a
site for college students and pretty
soon you realize you could sign up the
whole world if you wanted to
and at at this point most people's
reaction is fear
finding up the whole world seems like a
lot of work and it also seems like a
valuable prize and you have to fight to
win those the fear of big ideas prevents
most people from even realizing they
could start you know site fur for
college students and turn that into a
site for the whole world but a few
people are more excited than afraid when
this happens another thing I notice
about the founders of the really huge
startups is that I would not want to
stand between something they wanted and
them all a hundred hundred percent of
them have exceptional exceptional Drive
but it's not always straightforward to
tell how driven someone is drive can be
suppressed when someone else has
authority over you like in most schools
or in a job and in these situations
people who are really driven may even
read as less promising than people who
are merely obedient so not only is it
hard for me to tell how driven someone
is people often can't even tell
themselves
you can tell after they start a start-up
though no one has authority over you in
a start-up most people find the
authority vacuum uncomfortable but a few
people expand into it and those few
people think ah this is what life is
supposed to be like drive by itself is
not enough though you have to be driven
to work on this particular company in
all the really huge startups the company
is at least one of the founders life's
work
so they'd never willingly be acquired
for example if you sell your life's work
then what are you going to do early on
starting a start-up is all about the
product but that changes as a start-up
gets really big a founder who wants to
keep running the company has to become a
manager you don't have to have
management ability initially there's
plenty of empirical evidence to show
that you can learn this on the job but
you have to be able to learn it and you
probably even have to like it
designing cool products and managing
people are really different things most
people who like building things dislike
the idea of being a manager probably
know some people like that
it's a rare person who can be great at
both but you have to be if you want to
create one of the really big startups
those are the nine things as far as I
can tell that are the differences
between startups that are merely
successful and the ones that become
really big but they're not just a list
when you put them all together they make
a story of how a unicorn happens the
founders work on something their
experience just shows them that the
world needs it wouldn't seem like a
promising idea to most people but the
founders work on it anyway
partly because they understand the
promise of the idea a little bit better
and partly just because they think it's
cool they work on the idea and they
realize they become even bigger than
they had realized instead of shrinking
from this realization they embrace it
eagerly and they realize this is what
they want to do with their lives
and they're so committed to the company
that they're willing to morph themselves
into whatever the company needs there's
a lot of variety in startups but this is
the most common path for the really big
ones
so remember you don't have to start a
startup and if you do it doesn't have to
be a unicorn but if you do this is
probably what it's going to look like an
unpromising idea that blossoms into a
frightening Li big one and driven
founders who see the opportunity and run
with it
and I'm hoping that there are some of
you in this audience who hear this
description and think to themselves oh
my gosh it's like she's describing me
the people on the path to becoming huge
don't usually realize it themselves
early on but I'm hoping if I can
encourage even a few of you to keep
going then when you're successful your
example will encourage more new more new
women to start their own companies and
yes this is a very long term plan but
after all it's my life's work so thank
you
you
you